en tout cas côté fournitures scolaires
ces élèves sont parés dans ce collège de
l'agglomération chalonnaise une centaine
de familles à profiter de la commande
groupée d'une fédération de parents
d'élèves
moyennant 8 euros de cotisation à cette
association
les voilà doté d'une montagne de cahiers
de classeurs et de stylos à prix coûtant
1 qu'il de 40 euros correspondant à la
liste des enseignants à la virgule près
vous vous souciez d'en haut est étonnant
c'est quand même plus pratique n'a pas
besoin de courir les magasins et on a
tous directement on n'a pas besoin de
dépenser des heures dans un magasin et
cherchez pas trouvé ce qu'on veut
exactement
on a comparé par rapport aux autres aux
autres années mais c'est vrai que
financièrement c'est quand même c'est
quand même un gros gars de d'argent il
ya bien un accueil ça va mais si les
autres car la rentrée scolaire
représente toujours un sacré budget pour
les familles comptait cette année en
moyenne
177 euros pour un élève de cp 407 euros
pour un enfant rentrant au collège et
419 euros pour un lycéen de seconde
générale une facture de plus en plus
aller + 6 % par rapport à l'an dernier
dans ce contexte les parents
s'organisent ensemble on est plus fort
donc en achetant groupe et on arrive à
faire baisser les prix et à exiger des
produits de qualité ce qui permet aux
familles quelles que soient leurs
revenus d'avoir des produits de qualité
de marque et sur la table quand à dire
sur la table des cols ya pas de
différence quand on arrive avec un kit
sélectionnés et bien les enfants sont
tous un niveau d'égalité
une opération qui soulage le porte
monnaie des parents alors qu'ils auront
à assumer une dépense inédite qui va
vite chiffré le coût des masques
obligatoire à partir de 11 ans pour
leurs chères têtes blondes